It's a how-to manual, just six pages long, written by a sixth grader in Brooklyn named Peter. He handed it in to his teacher three years ago. She still has it.
这是一本操作指南，仅有六页长，由布鲁克林的一名六年级学生彼得编写。三年前他交给了老师，老师至今还留着它。
I keep it on my bulletin board by my refrigerator in case-- both for amusement and also in case I ever need to consult it.
我把它放在冰箱旁边的布告栏上，既是为了好玩，也以防万一哪天我需要参考它。
The manual gives step-by-step instructions on how to protect yourself from all sorts of unwanted visitors, that's all sorts of unwanted visitors says the teacher, Melissa Cantor.
这本手册提供了如何保护自己免受各种不速之客骚扰的分步指南，老师梅丽莎·坎特（Melissa Cantor）说，这包含了各种各样的不速之客。
There are a number of them. The first is the Wolfman. Then come aliens. Then there's one which is kind of a subtle digression, but it's along the same lines. It's if you have a bad dream.
不速之客有很多种。首先是狼人，接着是外星人。还有一种有点离题，但属于同一类，那就是如果你做了噩梦。
Which, in a way, is an unwanted visitor.
这在某种程度上也算是一个不速之客。
It so is. Really. It really is. And the final one is dinosaurs.
确实如此，真的，真的是这样。最后一种是恐龙。
If you have an unwanted visitor dinosaur?
如果你遇到了一个不速之客恐龙呢？
Right.
对。
The chapter on the Wolfman begins with this little pep talk. "First think," it says, "why would the Wolfman come to your house out of all the houses in Brooklyn?" But if you're afraid, here's what you do. Number one, sleep with a glass with water in it. Number two, Peter tells you to close the blinds, get under the covers, put a fan on.
关于狼人的那一章以一段小小的激励语开始。它写道：“首先想一想，为什么在布鲁克林所有的房子中，狼人会偏偏来你家？”但如果你感到害怕，就按照这样做：第一，睡觉时放一杯水；第二，彼得告诉你关上百叶窗，钻进被窝，打开风扇。
Number three, "if he comes in, put covers over your whole body. Don't move."
第三，“如果他进来了，把全身都盖在被子里，不要动。”
Like he'll never suspect you're there.
就好像他永远不会怀疑你在那里一样。
Exactly. This is what to do if a Wolfman with a low IQ comes to your house. "Four, if you want the satisfaction of killing him, take the glass and splash the water in his face." Then it switches. It says, B.
没错。这就是当一个智商不高的狼人来到你家时该做的事。“第四，如果你想体验击杀他的快感，拿起杯子把水泼在他脸上。”然后话题转换了，它写着“B”。
Wait, we've gone from one, two, three, four, and now we're going B, C, D?
等等，我们从一、二、三、四，现在变成B、C、D了？
Right.
对。
What's interesting is that one instinctively knows, even in the sixth grade, that if there's going to be a how-to, there are going to have to be steps and substeps.
有趣的是，人们会凭直觉知道，即使是在六年级，如果有一份操作指南，就必然会有步骤和子步骤。
Yes. I think in sixth grade-- I don't know if this is a digression or not. It is a digression. Can I digress, or should I stick to the text?
是的。我想在六年级——我不知道这算不算离题。确实离题了。我可以离题吗，还是应该坚持讲原文？
No, no, no. Digress away.
不，不，不。请随意离题。
In sixth grade, I think there's a general sense of kind of that the universe has an order, and they know a few key terms that guide that order. But some of the specifics sort of escape them. So for example, I had a sixth grader who wrote a story, and I knew it was a very, very steamy story, because when he went to give it to me, he was surrounded by all of his friends who were kind of giggling madly and sort of quite shocked that he gave it to me and then raced out of the room.
在六年级，我想人们普遍感觉到宇宙是有秩序的，他们知道一些指导这种秩序的关键术语。但一些具体细节他们可能不太清楚。例如，我曾有一名六年级学生写了一个故事，我知道那是一个非常非常肉麻的故事，因为当他把它交给我时，他周围所有的朋友都在疯狂地傻笑，而且非常震惊他竟然把它交给了我，然后他便跑出了教室。
And the story involved a man and a woman who were having a romantic evening in front of the fire. And there was soft music playing. And finally, to show that this was truly a romantic evening, the man takes a bottle of white wine-- it was very clear, white wine that they had been drinking-- and pours it all over the woman, which is I guess a sign that this is amorous.
故事讲的是一对男女在火炉前度过浪漫之夜，背景播放着柔和的音乐。最后，为了表现这确实是一个浪漫的夜晚，男人拿出一瓶白葡萄酒——非常明确是他们一直在喝的白葡萄酒——然后把它全部倒在女人身上，我想这大概是表示缠绵的一种标志。
The kid had the props right-- the fire, the soft music, the wine. He just wasn't clear on how everything fit together, which, in a way, happens all through this how-to. It's a hodgepodge. The dinosaur advice has images lifted straight from Jurassic Park . The Wolfman section has one practical piece of advice taken, really, from any middle-class dinner table in Brooklyn. "After you kill the Wolfman," it says, "if you think your mom will get mad from all the blood, take seltzer and paper towels and pat it. Then scrub."
这孩子道具准备得很对——火炉、柔和的音乐、酒。他只是不清楚这些元素该如何串联在一起，这在某种程度上也贯穿了整本操作指南。它就是一个大杂烩。关于恐龙的建议直接照搬了《侏罗纪公园》的图片。关于狼人的部分有一条实际建议，确实摘自布鲁克林任何一个中产阶级餐桌上的常识：“在你杀死狼人后，”它写道，“如果你认为你妈妈会因为血迹而生气，用苏打水和纸巾轻轻擦拭，然后刷洗干净。”
Why do you think he did this as a how-to? What is it about the how-to form that would be so attractive?
你为什么认为他要把这些写成操作指南的形式？操作指南这种形式有什么吸引力？
I think that the how-to form makes it seem like the world will follow certain rules. And if you follow certain rules, you'll be safe. And it puts it, I think, in your control. Because obviously, you have no control over whether or not the Wolfman or aliens come to your house.
我认为操作指南形式让世界看起来遵循着某些规则。如果你遵循这些规则，你就是安全的。这让你觉得一切尽在掌握。因为显然，对于狼人或外星人是否会来你家，你根本无法控制。
The how-to form. It's ingrained in us. It's part of what we are, how we make sense of the universe. Consider this story. In 1696, in England, the law changed, and suddenly people in England could publish whatever they wanted without getting it approved first by the king and his censor. And so there was this explosion of publishing. And within just a few decades, the single most popular kind of book, as soon as people could sell and buy any kind of books they chose, these were how-to books. In particular, how-to books written to teach people, mostly women, how, through education, self-control, and hard work, any family could better itself, could enter what we come to think of now as the middle class.
操作指南的形式已经根植于我们心中。它是我们的一部分，是我们理解宇宙的方式。考虑一下这个故事。1696年，英国法律发生变更，人们突然可以出版任何他们想出版的东西，而无需先经过国王及其审查员的批准。于是出版业出现了爆炸式增长。仅仅几十年内，最受欢迎的书籍类型，也就是人们一旦可以选择购买任何书籍时，就会选择操作指南。特别是那些专门教导人们——主要是女性——如何通过教育、自制力和勤奋工作，让任何家庭都能改善生活，进入我们现在所认为的中产阶级阶层。
And here's where it gets interesting. The advice books on how to become middle class came before the existence of an actual middle class. People followed the how-to instructions, bettered themselves, and the middle class emerged. We would not be who we are today without how-to. There's a straight line from those 18th century books of personal betterment to every Tony Robbins infomercial, every Jane Fonda workout video, every Martha Stewart magazine article-- stuff that gives you both step-by-step instructions and a motivational dream, a dream that you can transform yourself into a different person.
有趣的地方就在这里。关于如何成为中产阶级的指导书籍出现的时间，比中产阶级的实际存在还要早。人们遵循这些指南，提升了自己，中产阶级随之诞生。没有操作指南，就不会有今天的我们。从18世纪那些关于个人完善的书籍，到每一个托尼·罗宾斯（Tony Robbins）的电视广告、每一盘简·方达（Jane Fonda）的健身录像、每一篇玛莎·斯图尔特（Martha Stewart）的杂志文章，这之间有一条直接的脉络——这些内容不仅提供分步说明，还提供了一种激励性的梦想，一种你可以将自己转变成另一个人的梦想。
Which brings us to today's show. Each week on our program, of course we choose theme and bring you a variety of different stories on that theme. Today's show, how-to's, and what happens during a how-to, and what our how-to's say about us.
这带出了我们今天的节目。每周我们都会选择一个主题，并带来一系列关于该主题的故事。今天的节目主题是“操作指南”，以及操作指南过程中发生的事情，还有这些指南反映出的我们自身。
Act One of today's show, Roadrunner, in which I teach one of our regular contributors, Sarah Vowell, how to drive, and I find out that a simple how-to is never as simple as you think.
今天节目的第一幕《公路跑者》（Roadrunner），我教我们的常驻撰稿人莎拉·沃威尔（Sarah Vowell）开车，我发现一个简单的操作指南从来不像你想象的那么简单。
Act Two, How to Date a Blackgirl, Browngirl, Whitegirl, or Halfie. Junot Diaz explains what to do with the government-issued cheese in the refrigerator when you bring a date over to the house.
第二幕《如何与黑人、棕色皮肤女孩、白人女孩或混血女孩约会》。朱诺·迪亚斯（Junot Diaz）解释了当你带约会对象回家时，该如何处理冰箱里政府发放的奶酪。
Act Three, How to Increase Your Value as a Person, an act in which we try to tackle the biggest possible how-to we could think of, how to make your life worth more. And we get answers, real practical answers. Stay with this.
第三幕《如何提升你作为一个人的价值》，在这一幕中，我们尝试处理我们能想到的最大的操作指南，即如何让你的人生更有价值。我们将得到答案，非常实际的答案。请继续收听。
Act One, Roadrunner. We don't even agree on where this story begins. As far as I was concerned, it was just another how-to story. Our contributing editor Sarah Vowell wanted to learn how to drive, and I would teach her in two quick lessons.
第一幕《公路跑者》。关于这个故事从哪里开始，我们甚至意见都不统一。在我看来，这只是另一个操作指南故事。我们的特约编辑莎拉·沃威尔想学开车，而我会在两堂速成课中教会她。
For me, it wasn't even about driving. It was about fear. Nothing scares me more than driving. Nothing. I can't even ride a bike without mangling my digits and hitting parked cars. I've always been terrified that I'd get behind the wheel and it would be a big Shangri-La song with people screaming, "Look out! Look out! Look out! Look out!" Somehow I didn't mention this to Ira before we began.
对我来说，这甚至无关开车。这关乎恐惧。没有什么比开车更让我害怕了。真的什么都没有。我连骑自行车都会伤到手指并撞上停着的车。我一直很恐惧，如果我坐进驾驶座，就会像香格里拉乐队那首充满尖叫的歌一样：“小心！小心！小心！小心！”不知何故，在我们开始之前，我没有把这一点告诉艾拉（Ira）。
And this, I think, is how it usually goes with any how-to. A how-to seems like the most rational, orderly thing in the world. You know you do step one. You do step two, step three. Follow the diagram and instructions. Before you know it, creme brulee or the toy train set is assembled, or you're a more effective, convincing public speaker, whatever. But in fact, the logical step-by-step process is just a veneer of civilization cutting the vast paranoia that is not knowing, and the process of learning itself, which is inherently irrational, which brings us to the car guys.
我想，任何操作指南通常都是这样的。操作指南看起来是世界上最理性、最有序的东西。你知道你要做第一步，做第二步、第三步。照着图表和说明做。在你知道之前，焦糖布丁或玩具火车就已经组装好了，或者你已经成为了一名更有效、更有说服力的公众演说家，等等。但实际上，逻辑性的分步过程只是一层文明的伪装，切断了那种“不知道”所带来的巨大偏执，而学习过程本身本质上是非理性的，这把我们带到了修车哥们那里。
Hey.
嘿。
Hello?
喂？
Tom and Ray?
汤姆（Tom）和雷（Ray）？
Yeah, who's this? Is this Ira?
对，哪位？是艾拉吗？
Yeah, it's Ira.
对，是我，艾拉。
Hi, Ira.
嗨，艾拉。
How are you guys doing?
你们好吗？
We're doing great. What's up, man?
我们很好。什么事，伙计？
These of course, are Tom and Ray Magliozzi, hosts of NPR's Car Talk . I called them up to ask for practical advice on how to teach Sarah how to drive.
这些人当然就是汤姆和雷·马格利奥齐（Tom and Ray Magliozzi），NPR节目《汽车谈话》（Car Talk）的主持人。我打电话给他们，询问关于教莎拉开车的实用建议。
There isn't one person in 20,000 that knows the correct way to take a left turn. The rule simply is, you continue in the lane you're driving in until you get into what is the right lane of the lane you're turning to, right? Now what happens when a car is coming in the other direction which also wants to take a left turn? Got it?
两万人里没有一个人知道左转的正确方法。规则很简单，你在当前车道继续行驶，直到进入你要转入车道的右侧车道，对吧？现在，如果对面方向也有一辆车想左转会怎样？懂了吗？
Yeah, got it.
对，懂了。
What was I thinking? Tom and Ray articulated rules of the road so obscure that no one actually follows them.
我当时在想什么？汤姆和雷阐述的交通规则是如此生僻，以至于实际上根本没人遵守。
And there's not one driver in 50,000 who conforms to that rule.
五万人里没有一个司机符合那条规则。
Wait a second. And you're saying that I should teach her this way and not the way that every driver in America does it?
等一下。你的意思是说我应该这样教她，而不是美国每个司机都用的那种方法？
No, you should teach her the way that every driver does it because she'll be assassinated her first day out.
不，你应该教她每个司机都用的方法，因为她如果按我们的方法开车，第一天出门就会被暗杀。
[LAUGHS] Yeah, boy.
[笑声] 是啊，伙计。
No useful tips on steering or shifting or traffic, but the sages of Car Talk Plaza did have one prediction about what happens when you teach someone to drive.
关于转向、换挡或交通，他们没给什么有用的建议，但《汽车谈话》广场的智者们确实对教人开车时会发生什么有一个预测。
You have to be aware that things in your nature that you heretofore have kept secret from the entire world will be divulged to this person.
你必须意识到，你性格中那些迄今为止对全世界隐瞒的特质，都将向这个人暴露无遗。
Now wait a second. Are you giving me this advice out of personal experience on either of your part?
等等。你们是在用你们个人的经验给我提这个建议吗？
Oh, yeah.
噢，是的。
Absolutely. Keep us posted, Ira. And I look forward every Friday to hearing you on that science show that you work for.
绝对是。随时通知我们，艾拉。我每周五都期待在那个你工作的科学节目里听到你的声音。
That's the wrong Ira, you knucklehead.
那个艾拉不是我，你这个笨蛋。
Oh, boy.
噢，天哪。
When people ask me why I don't drive, I usually say, my sister drives. And to most people, that sounds like such a loony idea. But my sister and I are twins, and when you're a twin, there can be a very clear division of labor. I did the mental things. She did the physical ones. I learned to read before she did. She learned to ride a bike years before I did. Driving was her jurisdiction. Criticizing her driving was mine.
当人们问我为什么不开车时，我通常说，我姐姐开车。对大多数人来说，这听起来像个荒唐的想法。但我姐姐和我是双胞胎，当你是双胞胎时，会有非常明确的分工。我做脑力劳动，她做体力劳动。我比她先学会阅读。她比我早好几年学会骑自行车。开车是她的管辖范围。批评她的车技是我的。
After one humiliating attempt to learn when I was 16, I simply blocked the possibility out of my mind. I'm never going to drive, like I'm never going to murder anyone, like I'm never going to like Celine Dion. It was that huge.
在我16岁那次屈辱的尝试后，我简单地把这种可能性从脑海中抹去了。我永远不会开车，就像我永远不会谋杀任何人，就像我永远不会喜欢席琳·迪翁（Celine Dion）一样。这种态度就是如此强烈。
So it comes the day when Sarah's supposed to go down to the Department of Motor Vehicles to get her learner's permit. And she stops by, and I'm still thinking that we're just doing this little radio story, not realizing that, in fact, this is her greatest phobia. And I notice that she has this look on her face that I can only describe as pre-throw up, as she nervously flips through a copy of the Illinois state driving rules.
于是，到了莎拉应该去机动车辆管理局拿学员许可证的那天。她顺道过来，我还以为我们只是在做一个广播故事，没意识到，事实上，这就是她最大的恐惧。我注意到她脸上的表情，我只能形容为“准备呕吐”，她紧张地翻着一本伊利诺伊州驾驶规则手册。
So the second I opened it-- and this has been going on for days, you know. The second I opened it, I have been extremely anxious. It was like opening it up, boom. I was another person. I had just been tapping my fingers and nervous. It's like I just had 12 gallons of coffee. Am I sounding completely nervous and out of control and scared? Yeah.
所以我一打开它——这种情况已经持续好几天了，你知道。我一打开它，就变得极度焦虑。就像打开它一样，轰的一下。我变成了另一个人。我一直在敲手指，神经兮兮的。感觉就像刚喝了12加仑咖啡。我听起来是不是完全紧张、失控且恐惧？是的。
Yes.
是的。
Good. I'm communicating that.
太好了。我表达出来了。
You don't believe in your heart that you can actually control a car.
你内心并不相信自己真的能控制一辆车。
Nope.
没信心。
But that's the part that you're going to learn through this process.
但那正是你通过这个过程将要学会的部分。
I don't know. I just feel like this just isn't about me.
我不知道。我只是觉得这根本不关我的事。
What do you mean it isn't about you?
什么叫不关你的事？
This is for the car class.
这是为了那个汽车阶层。
What are you talking about?
你在说什么？
The car class is a specific class of people whom the American world is set up for. The car class in the elite. The car class is the upper class. The car class has all the power, makes all the rules. The car class occasionally throws a few dimes of taxes our way so that the non-car class can get places on the train. I mean, the car class burns fossil fuels. The car class, you know--
汽车阶层是一个特定的阶级，美国社会就是为他们建立的。汽车阶层是精英。汽车阶层是上层阶级。汽车阶层拥有所有的权力，制定所有的规则。汽车阶层偶尔扔几毛钱税款给我们，让非汽车阶层的人可以坐火车到处走。我是说，汽车阶层燃烧化石燃料。汽车阶层，你知道——
So you feel like the fact that I'm encouraging you-- like that you'll feel good if you can drive-- you just feel like--
所以你觉得我鼓励你——如果你会开车你会感觉良好——你只是觉得——
I'm joining a cult.
我加入了邪教。
Yeah.
是的。
One of us. One of us.
“你是我们的一员，你是我们的一员。”
Listening back to that conversation now, I am pained. I don't know who that humorless fanatic was. Though in my defense, I was grasping for any reason to get out of this driving mistake. Let me assure you that I care about fossil fuels precisely as much as everyone else in America, which is to say not at all.
现在回听这段对话，我感到很痛苦。我不知道那个毫无幽默感的狂热分子是谁。不过为自己辩护一下，我当时正拼命寻找任何理由来摆脱这个学车的错误决定。我向你保证，我对化石燃料的关心程度和美国其他人完全一样，也就是一点也不关心。
OK, one more thing.
好的，还有一件事。
Yeah.
嗯。
I told you what was my biggest fear. You have to tell me yours.
我告诉了你我最大的恐惧是什么。你得告诉我你的。
Women drivers.
女司机。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
So Sarah passes the test to get a learner's permit. I rent a car, and we head out to an elementary school parking lot.
所以莎拉通过了考试，拿到了学员许可证。我租了一辆车，我们前往小学停车场。
OK. What do I do? Should my feet be touching those pedals?
好的。我该怎么做？我的脚应该踩在踏板上吗？
They should be able to. So what you want to do is first you want to just get situated and adjust the mirrors and the seat. So push up the seat. Good.
应该能够到。所以你想做的第一件事就是坐好，调整后视镜和座椅。把座位调前一点。很好。
Wait. How much should my legs be bent?
等等。我的腿应该弯曲多少？
I was asking a lot of questions, not just because I wanted to know, but because I was stalling.
我问了很多问题，不仅仅因为我想知道，还因为我在拖延。
She asked about the mirror, as if reflective glass was this crazy, newfangled gadget.
她问关于后视镜的问题，仿佛反射镜是个什么疯狂的新奇玩意儿。
What am I supposed to see out of that?
我应该从那里面看到什么？
What you want to see is kind of like the side of the car just a little bit, and then you want to see what's next to the car.
你想看到一点点车侧，然后你想看到车旁边的景象。
OK.
好的。
OK?
可以吗？
OK.
可以。
This is the thing about a how-to. You find yourself explaining things, putting words into sentences that you never imagined you would ever be doing.
这就是操作指南的奥妙所在。你会发现自己在解释各种事情，把那些你从未想象过自己会说出的句子拼凑在一起。
After more stalling than we can possibly recount here on the radio, there was no avoiding the moment I'd been dreading since I was 15.
在经历了我们无法在此一一细数的拖延后，我从15岁起就一直恐惧的那一刻终究是躲不掉的。
I want to just give it a little bit of gas. I want you to be mindful there's only one car in this parking lot. I don't want us to hit it. So do that. You're going to keep going to the right. I want you to just give it a little bit of gas.
我想稍微踩一点点油门。我希望你注意一下，这个停车场里只有一辆车。我不想我们撞上它。所以这样做。你要保持向右行驶。我希望你只踩一点点油门。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
Let's just say that we just kind of lurched forward like one of those scenes in Star Trek where they're hit by a spaceship.
我们只能说，我们当时猛地向前冲了一下，就像《星际迷航》里被飞船撞击的场景一样。
And then we drove in circles. Literally, circles. And it was a surprisingly nonverbal kind of how-to. Mostly I just watched while Sarah got a feel for the car's controls, how much spin on the steering wheel actually turned the car, how much pressure on the gas pedal yielded how much speed. And I have to say, she was a natural.
然后我们绕着圈开车。真的是绕圈。而且这是一种出奇地非语言的操作指南。大多数时候我只是看着，同时莎拉慢慢感受汽车的操作，方向盘转动多少真正能让车转向，油门踩多少压力能产生多少速度。我不得不说，她很有天赋。
You are so good at this. I'm so impressed. Sarah, you are doing so well. Here's the tricky turn, though. Don't hit the handicapped people!
你真的很擅长这个。我印象深刻。莎拉，你做得太好了。不过这里有个棘手的转弯。别撞到残疾人！
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
It was like learning to play the piano, how in the beginning, you look at your hands as much as you look at the music. The hard thing isn't decoding the notes. It's doing it in time without stopping to think about every little move.
就像学弹钢琴一样，起初，你看手的时间和看乐谱的时间一样多。难的不是解码音符，而是在不中断思考每个动作的情况下，按节奏把它们弹出来。
I'm turning left and lurching, and turning right a little bit. And now I'm turning left a lot!
我在向左转，车在猛冲，稍微向右转一点。现在我在向左转很多！
After half an hour in which I played the driving equivalent of chopsticks, Ira took over the wheel again to take us to the next parking lot. I watched the streets while he drove, and suddenly they looked so narrow and fraught with the danger. My beautiful city of orderly boulevards and responsible fellow citizens now looked like some film noir back alley where you can't trust a soul, where a dame's pretty smile gets you nothing but the jaws of life, where even the parked cars looked like they were packing heat, and they didn't care who knew.
在半小时里，我上演了驾驶版的“筷子兄弟”（编者注：指简单初级弹奏），随后艾拉再次接管方向盘，把我们带到下一个停车场。我盯着街道，而他开车时，它们突然看起来如此狭窄且充满危险。我那座有着整齐大道和负责任公民的美丽城市，现在看起来像某个黑色电影中的小巷，在那里你不能信任任何人，那里美女的一抹微笑只会带来生命剪切钳，连停着的车看起来都像藏着枪，而且毫不在乎谁知道。
Meanwhile, in the real world, I looked for a bigger parking lot to practice driving in. And then we drove past Rosehill Cemetery. Perfect. Like a big, deserted public park with long winding roads, no cars, nobody around. Nobody we could hurt anyway.
与此同时，在现实世界里，我寻找一个更大的停车场来练习开车。然后我们经过了罗斯山公墓（Rosehill Cemetery）。太完美了。就像一个巨大的、荒废的公园，有漫长的蜿蜒道路，没有车，周围没人。反正也没人能被我们伤害到。
OK. I think we're clear. Huh? Yeah.
好的。我觉得我们安全了。哈？是的。
Sarah drove on snow. She handled intersections. I thought she was doing great. But then she started to act very, very strange.
莎拉在雪地上开车。她处理了交叉路口。我觉得她做得很好。但接着她开始表现得非常、非常奇怪。
I don't feel like myself right now. I'm having an outer body experience. I'm not really nervous anymore, but I'm not really concentrating.
我现在感觉不像我自己了。我有种灵魂出窍的体验。我不怎么紧张了，但我也不怎么能集中注意力。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
Well, that's reassuring.
嗯，这真让人放心。
My voice sounds different. Does my voice sound different? I don't sound like myself right now, do I?
我的声音听起来不一样了。我的声音听起来有区别吗？我现在听起来不像我自己，对吧？
In any how-to, there  are the actual skills that you're learning and then there is the fact that by learning these skills, you are actually becoming, in a small way, a different person. And during the how-to there's this period where you have the skills but you do not yet see yourself as a kind of person who has those skills, as the changed person. And this period, it can last for hours. It can last for years, really. Forever.
在任何操作指南中，都有你正在学习的实际技能，然后还有这样一个事实：通过学习这些技能，你在某种程度上实际上正在变成一个不同的人。在操作指南的过程中，有一个阶段，你已经掌握了技能，但你还没把自己看作是一个具备这些技能的人，一个改变后的人。这个阶段可能会持续几个小时。实际上，它可能会持续几年。永远持续。
There's a car behind me, huh?
后面有一辆车，哈？
Well, that's the way it's going to be.
嗯，事情就是这样。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
Who said they could come here?
谁说他们能来这里的？
Signal left.
打左转向灯。
I can't.
我不能。
Signal.
打灯。
I can't.
我不能。
Signal. Signal. Now turn left.
打灯。打灯。现在左转。
OK.
好的。
Slow down. No. Slow down. Not so much gas. Good.
减速。不。减速。油门别踩太多。很好。
I'd sort of forgotten there'd be other cars around. I had problems of my own without worrying about the other drivers, not just their actions, their actual existence.
我有点忘了周围会有其他车。我有我自己的问题，不用担心其他司机，不只是他们的行为，而是他们真实的存在。
And this brings us to the part of our story that we think of as the frightening near misses.
这带到了我们故事中我们认为的“惊险时刻”部分。
A word about this next recording before we play it for you. Remember, please, driving is my greatest fear. And it's not a totally irrational fear. There are things about driving that are in fact dangerous, like learning to pass another car without hitting it. So what happens when you confront the scariest part of your greatest fear? Well, I don't know about you, but I laugh, a lot.
在播放下一段录音之前说几句。记住，请记住，开车是我最大的恐惧。这不是完全不理性的恐惧。开车确实有些事情很危险，比如学习超越另一辆车而不撞到它。那么，当你面对你最大恐惧中最可怕的部分时会发生什么？好吧，我不知道你怎么想，但我会大笑，笑很久。
It was like that the first time when I was 16 and my sister tried to teach me to drive. I got behind the wheel and started giggling so maniacally and so uncontrollably for so long that she kicked me out of her car and made me walk.
就像我16岁时姐姐第一次试着教我开车一样。我坐上驾驶座，然后开始那种歇斯底里、无法抑制的长久傻笑，最后她把我赶下车，让我走路。
So all of which to say, the first two times that another car passed us on the road in the cemetery, Sarah drove straight off the street. Here's what it sounded like.
所以这一切意味着，在墓地里有车超越我们的前两次，莎拉直接把车开出了街道。听听当时的声音。
No. Sarah. Sarah.
不。莎拉。莎拉。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Sarah, now, listen. None of the wheels of this car is actually in the street right now.
莎拉，现在听着。这辆车的轮子现在一个都不在路面上。
Can't we just pretend like I did well? What was that? That's called panicking, isn't it? I saw the other car, and I just wanted to be away from it.
我们不能就假装我做得很好吗？那是什么？那叫恐慌，对吧？我看到另一辆车，我只想离它远点。
What I don't understand is you're doing so well. What do you have to panic about?
我不明白的是你做得这么好。你有什么好恐慌的？
Hitting it?
撞上它？
Hitting it.
撞上它。
I swerved away from it to protect them. That was actually a heroic move and not a cowardly one.
我为了保护他们而转向离开它。那实际上是一个英雄举动，而不是胆小的行为。
But I'm such a brand-new driver that I have no habits. Five minutes after I'd lurched away from the truck, a Buick passed, and I was compelled toward it like a magnet. Ira grabbed the wheel and swerved us away.
但我是一个全新的司机，我没有任何习惯。在卡车超过我们五分钟后，一辆别克车超过了我们，我像被磁铁吸引一样向它靠拢。艾拉抓住了方向盘把我们转开了。
Slow. Slow.
慢点。慢点。
This is the thing that I never suspected. I thought it was just going to be like, step one, step two, step three, easy, learn to drive, no problem. I never realized that I was actually going to get scared.
这就是我从未预料到的事。我以为那只是第一步、第二步、第三步，很简单，学开车，没问题。我从没意识到我真的会感到害怕。
"Oh, I look down on Sarah's fears. I thought Sarah's fears were unfounded. Sarah's just a scaredy cat, who, if she just thought things through like a rational human being--"
“噢，我瞧不起莎拉的恐惧。我以为莎拉的恐惧是没有根据的。莎拉只是个胆小鬼，如果她能像个理性的正常人一样把事情想清楚——”
Sarah Vowell. Sarah Vowell.
莎拉·沃威尔。莎拉·沃威尔。
Yes, Ira.
是的，艾拉。
You have to admit that this was not so hard. After only an hour in the cemetery, you were ready to drive among the living.
你得承认这没那么难。在墓地里才过了一个小时，你就准备好在人群中开车了。
Pull up a little more. After this car, I want you to go. Now. Stay in your lane.
再开过去一点。这辆车过后再走。现在。保持在你的车道。
[SIGHS]
[叹气]
Sarah looked to the left, looked to the right, and pulled into traffic down a narrow residential street.
莎拉看了左边，看了右边，然后汇入了一条狭窄住宅街道的交通流中。
I brought a tape, now that we're out on the road. Follow the curb here.
我带了一盘磁带，现在我们在路上开了。沿着路缘走。
[MUSIC - "ROADRUNNER" BY THE MODERN LOVERS]
[音乐 - 《公路跑者》, 摩登恋人乐队 (The Modern Lovers)]
Aw, you remembered!
噢，你记得！
[SINGING] Going faster miles an hour. Gonna drive past the Stop 'n' Shop. With the radio on.
[唱歌] 时速开得更快。我们要开过Stop 'n' Shop。听着广播。
Sarah named her first book after a line from this song, a song all about driving.
莎拉的第一本书就是以这首歌的一句歌词命名的，这首歌完全是关于开车的。
I thought it was all about listening to the radio.
我以为那全是在讲听广播。
Anyway, the celebration turned out to be a little premature.
总之，庆祝活动显得有点操之过急。
The song was so blissfully distracting, it was hard to keep pace with traffic. And four cars, in a kind of convergence of hate, honked a big, "Howdy, neighbor, welcome to the car class."
这首歌太令人愉快地分心了，很难跟上交通速度。而四辆车，带着一种仇恨的交集，大按喇叭，“嗨，邻居，欢迎来到汽车阶层。”
It suddenly seemed like a very good idea to turn off the tape.
突然觉得关掉磁带是个非常好的主意。
Eww.
哎呀。
[HORNS HONKING]
[喇叭声]
OK.
好的。
Turn off the stereo. Go to the right. Turn right. Turn right. You have a green.
关掉音响。向右走。右转。右转。你有绿灯。
All right. All right, everybody.
好的。好的，各位。
Good. Pull over here.
很好。停在这里。
Pull over?
停下？
Stop, stop, stop. Stop.
停，停，停。停下。
Despite the occasional close call, it was a very good start. But our second lesson the next day led us to a side of our how-to that-- I mean, I guess I should have seen this coming. After all, I did have the warning from the Garage Cassandras, the Bards of Stratford on Charles, the oracle at Car Talk Plaza.
尽管偶尔有险情，这还是一个非常好的开始。但第二天我们的第二堂课把我们带到了我们操作指南的另一面，我想我应该早点预料到这一点。毕竟，我有来自车库卡桑德拉（Garage Cassandras）、查尔斯河畔斯特拉特福吟游诗人、以及《汽车谈话》广场神谕者的警告。
Things in your nature that you heretofore have kept secret from the entire world will be divulged to this person.
你性格中那些迄今为止对全世界隐瞒的特质，都将向这个人暴露无遗。
We'd gotten along OK on the first day. Day two began with this insane claim on the part of my friend Sarah Vowell.
第一天我们相处得还行。第二天开始于我朋友莎拉·沃威尔的一项疯狂宣称。
Insane?
疯狂？
You claimed you hadn't driven.
你声称你没开过车。
I just feel very removed from the whole thing. I wasn't driving. I was doing a story.
我只是感觉自己完全置身事外。我没在开车，我是在做一个故事。
But you drove for two hours.
但你开了两个小时车。
Yeah.
是的。
But somehow you still think that you haven't driven.
但不知何故你仍然认为你没开过车。
Well, yeah, I mean, driving just isn't something I do. I mean, I guess I could see that physically, yes, I was doing it. And I remember being there in all of it. But I just felt like that was my evil twin or something. [LAUGHS]
好吧，我的意思是，开车根本不是我会做的事。我是说，我想我能看到在生理上，是的，我确实在做。我记得当时在场，也记得这一切。但我只是觉得那是我的邪恶双胞胎之类的。[笑声]
Yesterday when you and I were in the car, everything was just fine, right?
昨天当我们在车里时，一切都很好，对吧？
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
It was just fine. We got along fine.
很好。我们相处得很好。
It's only right now you're getting on my nerves.
只是现在你让我有点心烦。
That's what I was going to say. You're getting on my nerves. You are. I can't believe this. I mean, you can actually drive. And I don't know. Maybe this is just very boy, but I feel like I showed you how to drive and now you're turning around and you're telling me that it never happened.
那正是我要说的。你让我心烦。你确实是。我不敢相信。我是说，你真的会开车。我不知道。也许这很孩子气，但我感觉我教你怎么开车，现在你转过头来告诉我那件事从未发生。
I feel like you have this kind of you feel like you need to save me or something right now in a way that's bothering me.
我感觉你有一种——你觉得你需要拯救我或者类似的事情，这让我很不舒服。
Well, no, it isn't that I feel like I need to save you. It's that I feel like you don't know, but I know. I know better. It's a feeling of I know better. Not a very good feeling to bring up between two people. Not only is it a feeling of I know better. It's a feeling that I know better what you need.
好吧，不，并不是我觉得我需要拯救你。而是我觉得你不知道，但我知道。我知道得更多。这是一种“我比你懂”的感觉。在两个人之间提出这种感觉可不太好。不仅是“我比你懂”的感觉。这还是一种“我更清楚你需要什么”的感觉。
Hmm. I don't want to drive. And since I have driven, I feel like-- this is sort of weird, but it sort of feels like I would imagine how it feels to have an affair or something. I feel like I've cheated on myself. You know that while you're doing it that that's what you're doing and you can sort of feel yourself doing it. You can feel yourself touch this foreign object. And then the next morning, you just wish the whole thing had never happened. You just hope no one ever finds out.
嗯。我不想开车。既然我已经开过了，我觉得——这有点怪，但感觉就像我想象中的那种有外遇的感觉。我觉得我背叛了自己。你知道，当你做的时候，你知道自己在做什么，你可以感觉到自己在做。你可以感觉到自己在触碰这个陌生的物体。然后第二天早上，你只希望这一切从未发生过。你只希望没人会发现。
An impasse. Any teacher will tell you, in any how-to situation, there's the actual learning part and then, the trickiest part of all, motivation.
僵局。任何老师都会告诉你，在任何操作指南的情况下，都有实际的学习部分，然后是所有部分中最棘手的部分：激励。
I'm feeling a little deflated right now, like I need to be pumped up to go out. I need some fun encouragement to get back in the car again.
我现在感觉有点泄气，好像我需要被鼓舞一下才能再上路。我需要一些有趣的鼓励，好让我再次回到车里。
Sarah knew how to drive. She just didn't remember why she should drive. So I tried to evoke for her the picture of an America in which she could hit the open road, like Dean Moriarty, like driving is America, like there's a fundamental idea of what it is to be an American that is bound up in every hit-the-road song and movie and story that either of us have ever loved and probably you listening to my voice right now, in your car, listening to the radio that you also have loved, like, "it's waiting out there like a killer in the sun. Just one more chance. We can make it if we run." All of that. I went through all of it.
莎拉知道怎么开车。她只是不记得为什么要开车了。所以我试图为她勾勒出一幅美国的图景，在这里她可以像迪恩·莫里亚蒂（Dean Moriarty）一样走上开阔的道路，仿佛开车就是美国，仿佛有一种关于“成为美国人”的基本理念，被编织在每一首 हिट-the-road的歌曲、电影和故事里，这些是我们俩都热爱过的，可能你现在正坐在车里，听着广播，你也热爱着这些——比如，“它在那儿等着，像阳光下的杀手。再给一次机会。如果我们奔跑，就能成功。”所有这些，我都讲了一遍。
Didn't work. She mentioned something about the highway within that I didn't completely understand. So I switched tactics.
没用。她提到了某种关于公路的东西，我没完全明白。所以我换了策略。
To feel the freedom of the road, you don't need Jack Kerouac. You just need Jack in the Box. Drive-through.
要感受公路的自由，你不需要杰克·凯鲁亚克（Jack Kerouac）。你只需要杰克盒子快餐店（Jack in the Box）。得来速。
Drive-through. Really?
得来速。真的吗？
Let's go.
我们走吧。
OK.
好的。
I know most people think of the drive-through as a visual and gastronomic blight. But my sister and I are obsessed with them. Our dad wouldn't go through drive-throughs when we were growing up. I think they make him nervous, partly because he's deaf. He only approves of fast food when it's served on the fancy trays, so we think of drive-throughs as these objects of desire, full of the thrills denied to us so cruelly for so long.
我知道大多数人认为得来速是视觉和饮食上的糟粕。但我姐姐和我对它们痴迷。我们小时候，我爸爸不肯去得来速。我想那是让他紧张，部分是因为他是聋子。他只认可在精致托盘上供应的快餐，所以我们把得来速看作这些渴望的对象，充满了长期以来残忍剥夺给我们的刺激。
So what's it going to be then? Are you in the mood for Burger King or McDonald's or--
那你想吃什么？你想去汉堡王还是麦当劳，或者——
I want to go to a place that's on the right side of the street.
我想去一家在街道右侧的店。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
So you don't have to make a left turn?
所以你就不用左转了？
Yeah.
对。
Three left turns later, we pull into the drive-through lane of a Burger King.
三个左转弯后，我们驶入了汉堡王的得来速通道。
OK. You're doing great.
好的。你做得棒极了。
Look. We're at the thing.
看。我们在那玩意儿跟前了。
OK.
好的。
Can I take your order, please?
请问你要点什么？
We'd like a Whopper and two Cokes and one chicken sandwich.
我们要一个皇堡，两杯可乐，还有一个鸡肉三明治。
You want two Cokes, a Whopper, and a chicken sandwich?
你要两杯可乐，一个皇堡，和一个鸡肉三明治？
Uh-huh.
嗯。
Will that be all, ma'am?
还有别的吗，女士？
Yep.
好了。
Would you like any fries with that?
要不要加点薯条？
One fry.
一份薯条。
OK, that's two Cokes, a Whopper, a chicken sandwich, and a medium fry. Will that be all?
好的，那是两杯可乐、一个皇堡、一个鸡肉三明治和一份中份薯条。还有别的吗？
Uh-huh.
嗯。
OK, your total comes to $9.08. Drive through, please.
好的，一共9.08美元。请开过来。
OK. [LAUGHS] He said drive through, please, to me. To me. No one's ever said that to me before.
好的。[笑声] 他跟我说“请开过来”。对我。以前从来没人跟我说过这话。
Those of you familiar with the customs of life here in the United States of America need no explanation of what happens next. We give the guy some money. He gives us food.
熟悉美国生活习惯的各位，不需要解释接下来会发生什么。我们给那家伙一些钱。他给我们食物。
Notice. Notice. It's coming through the car window.
注意。注意。它从车窗伸进来了。
OK, there you go.
好了，给你。
Thank you.
谢谢。
You're welcome. Have a nice day.
不客气。祝你有美好的一天。
You too.
你也是。
We pulled into a parking space to eat.
我们把车停进停车位吃饭。
That was fun. [LAUGHS]
那很有意思。[笑声]
I have to say, this is probably going to be the best crappy sandwich I've ever had in my life.
我不得不说，这可能是我这辈子吃过最好吃的烂三明治。
It was a really remarkable thing to see. Half an hour before this, she never wanted to drive ever again, never wanted to join the part of our American culture that is behind the wheel. It was an epiphany, an actual epiphany, all taking place at a Burger King. She overcame the greatest fear of her life at a drive-through window.
那场面真是非凡。半小时前，她再也不想开车了，不想加入我们美国文化中那个坐在驾驶座的阶层。这是一个顿悟，一个真实的顿悟，全部发生在一家汉堡王。她在得来速窗口克服了她一生中最大的恐惧。
Let me ask you.
让我问你。
OK.
好的。
How many times do you think you'd have to do drive through before it would stop giving you this unbelievable thrill?
你觉得你得去多少次得来速，这种难以置信的快感才会消失？
Never.
永远不会。
Ever? Man, Sarah.
永远？天哪，莎拉。
I loved the way the guy looked at me and smiled and said, you know-- what did he say, something plain like enjoy your meal? But I felt like he really meant it.
我喜欢那家伙看着我微笑，然后说——你知道——他说了什么吗？一些平淡的话，比如“祝您用餐愉快”？但我感觉他是真心的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And now, my fellow Americans, we have arrived at the drive off into the sunset portion of our story, even though it was the middle of the day, even though we were heading east. We went up Irving Park Road to the highway, Lake Shore Drive, the most beautiful street in America.
现在，我的美国同胞们，我们来到了故事中“驶向日落”的部分，尽管当时是正午，尽管我们正向东开。我们沿着欧文公园路（Irving Park Road）开上高速公路，湖滨大道（Lake Shore Drive），美国最美丽的街道。
Trees and old beautiful buildings, the whole city of Chicago to our right. Lake Michigan to our left. Eight lanes of speeding cars. We merged.
树木和古老美丽的建筑，整个芝加哥市在我们右侧。密歇根湖在我们左侧。八车道的高速车辆。我们汇入了。
Now I'm feeling kind of giddy. But you know what?
我现在感觉有点飘飘然。但你知道吗？
What?
什么？
I feel like I'm driving.
我觉得我正在开车。
You do.
你确实在开。
Yes. No alternate personalities are in charge of this vehicle at this moment.
是的。此刻这辆车没有其他的人格在掌管。
That's good to know. Follow that white car.
很高兴知道这一点。跟着那辆白车。
OK.
好的。
OK, whatever they do, you do.
好了，不管他们做什么，你跟着做。
[SINGING] Anything you can do, I can  do better. I can do anything better than you.
[唱歌] 你能做的任何事，我都能做得更好。我能做的任何事都比你好。
No, you can't.
不，你不能。
Yes, I can.
是的，我可以。
No, you can't.
不，你不能。
Yes, I can.
是的，我可以。
No, you can't.
不，你不能。
OK, it's true.
好吧，这是真的。
[MUSIC - "ROADRUNNER" BY THE MODERN LOVERS]
[音乐 - 《公路跑者》, 摩登恋人乐队]
Coming up, if she's from the neighborhood, take her to El Cibao to eat. If she's not, Wendy's will do. And after dinner, what to say when you see the sunset and other how-to's including how to value your own life, in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，如果她是本地人，带她去El Cibao吃饭。如果不是，Wendy's就行。晚餐后，当你看到日落时该说什么，还有其他操作指南，包括如何衡量你自己的生命价值，来自公共广播国际 (PRI) 的节目，稍后继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, invite a variety of writers and reporters and performers to tackle that theme. Today's program, How-to. What happens during a how-to, what our how-to's say about us. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, How to Date a Browngirl, Blackgirl, Whitegirl, or Halfie.
这是《美国生活》(This American Life)。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，邀请各种作家、记者和表演者来探讨这个主题。今天的节目主题是“操作指南”。操作指南过程中发生的事情，这些指南反映出的我们自身。我们进入了节目的第二幕。《如何与黑人、棕色皮肤女孩、白人女孩或混血女孩约会》。
You know, one of the most common kinds of how-to's, going back to when they begin has always involved how to act to seem attractive to someone else. In that genre, we offer this story from Junot Diaz. A warning that some of this might not be suitable for younger listeners.
你知道，最常见的操作指南之一，从起源开始，一直涉及如何表现得吸引别人。在这一类中，我们提供这个来自朱诺·迪亚斯的故事。警告：其中一些内容可能不适合年轻听众。
Wait for your brother and your mother to leave the apartment. You've already told them that you're feeling too sick to go to Union City to visit that tia who likes to squeeze your nuts. "He's gotten big," she'll say. And even though your moms knows you ain't sick, you stuck to your story until finally she said, "Go ahead and stay, malcriado."
等你的兄弟和妈妈离开公寓。你已经告诉她们你感觉病得太重，不能去联合市（Union City）看那个喜欢捏你蛋蛋的阿姨。“他长大了，”她会说。即使你妈妈知道你没病，你还是坚持你的说法，直到最后她说：“走吧，留着吧，没教养的家伙（malcriado）。”
Clear the government cheese from the refrigerator. If the girl's from the Terrace, stack the boxes behind the milk. If she's from the Park or Society Hill, hide the cheese in the cabinet above the oven, way up where she'll never see. Leave yourself a reminder to get it out before morning or your moms will kick your ass.
把政府发放的奶酪从冰箱里清理出来。如果那个女孩来自露台区（Terrace），把盒子叠在牛奶后面。如果她来自公园区或社会山（Society Hill），把奶酪藏在烤箱上方的柜子里，放在她永远看不到的高处。提醒自己早上把它拿出来，否则你妈妈会揍死你的。
Take down any embarrassing photos of your family in the campo, especially the one with the half naked kids dragging a goat on a rope leash. The kids are your cousins, and by now they're old enough to understand why you're doing what you're doing. Hide the pictures of yourself with an Afro. Make sure the bathroom is presentable. Put the basket with all the crapped-on toilet paper under the sink. Spray the bucket with the Lysol, then close the cabinet. Shower, comb, dress. Sit on the couch and watch TV.
把墙上所有关于你在乡下（campo）家人的尴尬照片拿下来，特别是那张半裸的孩子拖着一只系绳山羊的照片。孩子们是你的表亲，现在他们长大了，懂为什么你要这么做了。藏起你留着非洲头（Afro）的照片。确保浴室看起来体面。把装满用过厕纸的篮子塞到水槽下面。用空气清新剂喷一下桶，然后关上柜子。洗澡，梳头，穿衣。坐在沙发上看电视。
If she's an outsider, her father will be bringing her, maybe her mother. Neither of them want her seeing any boys from the Terrace. People get stabbed in the Terrace. But she's strongheaded, and this time will get her way. If she's a white girl, you know you'll at least get a hand job.
如果她是外来者，她父亲会带她来，也许还有她母亲。他们都不想让她见任何来自露台区的男孩。露台区有人会被捅伤。但她很固执，这次她会如愿以偿。如果她是白人女孩，你知道你至少能得到一次手淫。
The directions were in your best handwriting, so her parents won't think you're an idiot. Get up from the couch and check the parking lot. Nothing. If the girl's local, don't sweat it. She'll flow over when she's good and ready. Sometimes she'll run into her other friends, and a whole crowd will show up at your apartment. And even though that means you ain't getting [BLEEP], it will be fun anyway and you'll wish these people would come over more often.
说明书是你用最好的笔迹写的，所以她的父母不会认为你是傻瓜。从沙发上站起来，看看停车场。什么都没有。如果女孩是本地人，别担心。等她准备好了自然会过来。有时她会碰到其他朋友，一大群人会出现在你公寓里。即使这意味着你什么也得不到，但这也会很有趣，你会希望这些人能多来几次。
Sometimes the girl won't flow over at all, and the next day in school, she'll say, sorry, and smile. And you'll be stupid enough to believe her and ask her out again.
有时女孩根本不会过来，第二天在学校，她会说“抱歉”，然后微笑。而你会蠢到相信她，并再次约她。
Wait, and after an hour, go out to your corner. The neighborhood is full of traffic. Give one of your boys a shout, and when he says, "Are you still waiting on that bitch?" say, "Hell yeah." Get back inside. Call her house. And when her father picks up, ask if she's there. He'll ask, "Who is this?" Hang up. He sounds like a principal or a police chief, the sort of dude with a big neck who never has to watch his back.
等等，过了一个小时，去你的街角。街区里交通繁忙。给你的朋友叫一声，当他说，“你还在等那个碧池吗？”说，“当然啦。”回到屋里。打她家电话。当她父亲接听时，问她在不在。他会问，“你是谁？”挂掉。他听起来像校长或警察局长，那种脖子粗、从不用担心背后的人。
Sit and wait. By the time your stomach's ready to give out on you, a Honda or maybe a Jeep pulls in, and out she comes. "Hey," you'll say. "Look," she'll say, "my mom wants to meet you. She's got herself all worried about nothing." Don't panic. Say, "Hey, no problem." Run a hand through your hair like the white boys do, even though the only thing that runs easily through your hair is Africa.
坐着等。等到你的胃快要支撑不住时，一辆本田或吉普车开进来了，她出来了。“嘿，”你会说。“看，”她说，“我妈想见你。她担心得要命。”别慌。说，“嘿，没问题。”像白人男孩那样用手捋一下头发，尽管你头发里唯一能轻易穿过的只有非洲。
She will look good. The white ones are the ones you want the most, but usually the out-of-towners are black-- black girls who grew up with ballet and Girl Scouts, who have three cars in their driveways. If she's a halfie, don't be surprised that her mother is white. Say hi. Her moms will say hi, and you will see that you don't scare her, not really.
她会看起来很漂亮。白人女孩是你最想要的，但通常外地人是黑人——那些从小跳芭蕾舞、参加女童军、车道上停着三辆车的黑人女孩。如果她是混血儿，别惊讶她母亲是白人。打招呼。她妈妈会回礼，你会发现你并不吓人，真的。
She will say that she needs easier directions to get out. And even though she has the best directions in her lap, give her new ones. Make her happy.
她会说她需要更简单的路线才能出去。即使她膝盖上放着最好的路线指引，也要给她新的。让她开心。
You have choices. If the girl is from around the way, take her to El Cibao for dinner. Order everything in your busted up Spanish. Let her correct you if she's Latina, and amaze her if she's black. If she's not from around the way, Wendy's will do.
你有选择。如果女孩是本地人，带她去El Cibao吃晚餐。用你蹩脚的西班牙语点所有的菜。如果是拉美裔，让她纠正你；如果是黑人，让她感到惊奇。如果她不是本地人，Wendy's就行。
As you walk to the restaurant, talk about school. A local girl won't need the stories about the neighborhood, but the other ones might. Supply the story about the loco who had been storing canisters of tear gas in his basement for years, how one day the canisters cracked and the whole neighborhood got a dose of the military strength stuff. Don't tell her that your moms knew right away what it was, that she recognized its smell from the year the United States invaded your island.
走路去餐厅时，聊聊学校。本地女孩不需要关于街区的故事，但其他女孩可能会。讲讲那个在地下室储存了多年催泪瓦斯罐的疯子的故事，有一天罐子裂开了，整个街区都遭到了军用级别的打击。别告诉她你妈妈立刻就知道那是什么，她从美国入侵你们岛的那一年就认出了那股气味。
Hope that you don't run into your nemesis, Howie, the Puerto Rican kid with the two killer mutts. He walks them all over the neighborhood, and every now and then, the mutts corner themselves a cat and tear it to shreds. Howie laughing as the cat flips up in the air, its neck twisted around like an owl, red meat showing through the soft fur. If his dogs haven't cornered a cat, he will walk behind you and ask, "Hey, Junior, is that your new [BLEEP]?" Let him talk.
希望你别碰到你的死对头，霍伊（Howie），那个养了两条杀手混种狗的波多黎各小子。他牵着它们在街区到处走，每隔一段时间，狗就会把猫逼进死角撕成碎片。霍伊大笑着看着猫被踢到空中，脖子像猫头鹰一样扭曲，红肉透过柔软的皮毛显露出来。如果他的狗还没逼住猫，他会跟在你后面问，“嘿，朱尼奥，这是你的新碧池吗？”随他去说吧。
Howie weighs about 200 pounds and could eat you if he wanted. At the field, he will turn away. He has new sneakers and doesn't want them muddy. If the girl's an outsider, she will hiss now and say, "What a [BLEEP] asshole." A homegirl would have been yelling back at him the whole time unless she was shy. Either way, don't feel bad that you didn't do anything. Never lose a fight on your first date or that will be the end of it.
霍伊体重约200磅，如果他想的话能把你生吞了。在田野里，他会走开。他有新运动鞋，不想弄脏。如果女孩是外地人，她现在会嘶嘶地说，“真是个混蛋。”如果是本地女孩，除非她害羞，否则早就一直跟他对骂了。无论如何，别因为没做什么而感到难过。永远不要在第一次约会就输掉一场架，否则那就会是结局。
Dinner will be tense. You are not good at talking to people you don't know. A halfie will tell you that her parents met in the movement, will say, "Back then, people thought it a radical thing to do." It will sound like something her parents made her memorize. Your brother once heard that one and said, "Man, that sounds like a whole lot of Uncle Tomming to me." Don't repeat this. Put down your hamburger and say, "It must have been hard." She will appreciate your interest. She will tell you more. "Black people," she will say, "treat me real bad. That's why I don't like them."
晚餐会很紧张。你不擅长与不认识的人交谈。一个混血女孩会告诉你她的父母是在运动中相识的，会说，“当时，人们认为这是一件激进的事。”这听起来像是她父母让她背诵的东西。你兄弟曾经听过这个，说，“伙计，这听起来简直像是彻头彻尾的卖国求荣。”别重复这句话。放下你的汉堡说，“那一定很艰难。”她会感激你的兴趣。她会告诉你更多。“黑人，”她会说，“对我非常不好。所以我才不喜欢他们。”
You'll wonder how she feels about Dominicans. Don't ask. Let her speak on it, and when you're both finished eating, walk back into the neighborhood. The skies will be magnificent. Pollutants have made Jersey sunsets one of the wonders of the world. Point it out. Touch her shoulder and say, "That's nice, right?"
你会好奇她对多米尼加人是什么感觉。别问。让她说出来，当你们都吃完后，走回街区。天空会变得壮丽。污染物使泽西岛的日落成为世界奇观之一。指出这一点。碰碰她的肩膀说，“那很漂亮，对吧？”
Get serious. Watch TV, but stay alert. Sip some of the rum your father left in the cabinet, which nobody touches. A local girl may have hips and a thick ass, but she won't be quick about letting you touch. She has to live in the same neighborhood as you, has to deal with you being in her business. She might just chill with you and then go home. She might kiss you and then go. Or she might, if she's reckless, give it up, but that's rare. Kissing will suffice.
认真点。看电视，但保持警惕。抿一口你父亲留在柜子里没人动过的朗姆酒。本地女孩可能有翘臀，但她不会轻易让你碰。她必须和你住在同一个街区，必须应付你介入她的生活。她可能只是和你放松一下然后回家。她可能会吻你然后走掉。或者，如果她鲁莽的话，她可能会奉献出来，但这很少见。亲吻就足够了。
A white girl might just give it up right then. Don't stop her. She'll take her gum out of her mouth, stick it to the plastic sofa covers, and then will move close to you. "You have nice eyes," she might say. Tell her that you love her hair, that you love her skin, her lips, because in truth, you love them more than you love your own. She will say, "I like Spanish guys." And even though you've never been to Spain, say, "I like you." You'll sound smooth.
白人女孩可能当时就给了。别阻止她。她会把口香糖从嘴里拿出来，粘在塑料沙发套上，然后靠近你。“你有双漂亮的眼睛，”她可能会说。告诉她你爱她的头发，你爱她的皮肤、她的嘴唇，因为事实上，你爱它们胜过爱你自己。她会说，“我喜欢西班牙男孩。”即使你从没去过西班牙，也要说，“我喜欢你。”你会显得很老练。
You'll be with her until about 8:30, and then she'll want to wash up. In the bathroom, she will hum a song from the radio and her waist will keep the beat against the lip of the sink. Imagine her old lady coming to get her, what she would say if she knew her daughter had just laid under you and blown your name, pronounced with her eighth grade Spanish, into your ear. While she's in the bathroom, call one of your boys and say, Lo hice, loco. Or just sit back on the couch and smile.
你会和她待到8:30左右，然后她会想洗洗。在浴室里，她会哼着广播里的歌，腰部随着水槽边缘打着节拍。想象一下她母亲来接她，如果她知道她女儿刚刚躺在你身下，用她八年级的西班牙语把你的名字吹进你耳里，她会说什么。当她在浴室时，打给你的一个兄弟说，“我做到了（Lo hice, loco）。”或者只是靠在沙发上微笑。
But usually-- usually it won't work this way. Be prepared. She will not want to kiss you. "Just cool it," she'll say. The halfie might lean back, breaking away from you. She will cross her arms, say, "I hate my tits." Stroke her hair, but she will pull away. "I don't like anyone touching my hair," she will say. She will act like somebody you don't know. In school, she is known for her attention-grabbing laugh, as high and far ranging as a gull. But here she will worry you. You will not know what to say. "You're the only kind of guy who asks me out," she will say. "You and the black boys."
但通常——通常不会这样。做好准备。她不会想吻你。“冷静点，”她会说。混血女孩可能会后仰，避开你。她会交叉双臂说，“我讨厌我的胸部。”抚摸她的头发，但她会缩回去。“我不喜欢任何人碰我的头发，”她说。她会表现得像个你不认识的人。在学校，她以引人注目的笑声著称，像海鸥一样高昂而遥远。但在这里，她会让你担心。你不知道该说什么。“你是唯一一个约我的那种男孩，”她说。“你和那些黑人男孩。”
Say nothing. Let her button her shirt. Let her comb her hair, the sound of it stretching like a sheet of fire between you. When her father pulls in and beeps, let her go without too much of a goodbye. She won't want it. During the next hour, the phone will ring. You will be tempted to pick it up. Don't. Watch the shows you want to watch without a family around to debate you. Don't go downstairs. Don't fall asleep. It won't help. Put the government cheese back in its place before your mother kills you.
什么都别说。让她扣好衬衫。让她梳好头发，声音像sheets of fire一样在你们之间延伸。当她父亲开车进来并按喇叭时，让她走，不要太多告别。她不会想要的。接下来的一个小时里，电话会响。你会忍不住想接。别接。看你想看的电视节目，周围没有家人来和你争论。别下楼。别睡着。那没用。在把你妈气死之前，把政府奶酪放回原位。
Junot Diaz's story is in his book Drown.
朱诺·迪亚斯的这个故事收录在他的书《溺水》（Drown）中。
[MUSIC - "FINE BROWN FRAME" BY NELLIE LUTCHER]
[音乐 - 《Fine Brown Frame》, 奈莉·卢彻 (Nellie Lutcher)]
Act Three, How to Increase Your Value as a Person. Most how-to's make a promise. You're not just going to learn skills. You will be transformed. So, putting together today's program, we thought, what would be the ultimate transformation? What how-to could actually increase the value of human life? And it turns out that we as a society have people whose job it is to think about this very question. And they turned out to be insurance adjusters. Insurance adjusters.
第三幕《如何提升你作为一个人的价值》。大多数操作指南都会做出承诺。你不仅会学习技能，还会发生蜕变。所以，在筹备今天的节目时，我们想，什么才是最终极的蜕变？什么操作指南可以真正提升人类生命的价值？事实证明，作为一个社会，我们有专门负责思考这个问题的人。他们竟然是保险理算员。保险理算员。
When somebody dies, insurance adjusters review the facts of the case, consider how much juries usually pay for various kinds of lifes and deaths when somebody dies and somebody else is to blame. And then the adjusters recommend how much the insurance company should settle for, what the life was worth. Adam Davidson put together this how-to on how to increase the value of your life.
当有人去世时，保险理算员会审查案件的事实，考虑当有人过错导致他人死亡时，陪审团通常会支付多少赔偿金。然后，理算员会建议保险公司应该赔付多少，即这个人的生命值多少钱。亚当·戴维森（Adam Davidson）整理了这篇关于如何提升你生命价值的操作指南。
When I was seven, my mom told me about a guy who died because his car blew up. It was the manufacturer's fault, and the man's relatives sued and got about $300,000. I remember wondering about that number. I remember thinking if you were going to assign a number to a human life, it would have to be huge, at least a million. To my seven-year-old mind, a million seemed like the start of the really big numbers.
我七岁时，妈妈告诉我一个人的事，他因为汽车爆炸而死。那是制造商的错，那个人的亲属起诉并获得了大约30万美元。我记得我对那个数字很好奇。我记得我在想，如果你要给一个人的生命标价，那肯定是个巨大的数字，至少一百万。在七岁的我看来，一百万似乎是真正大数字的开端。
The other day, I wanted to find out how much my life was worth, so I went to talk to this guy George Karas, an adjuster in Merrillville, Indiana. He looked me over, asked me my stats-- age, job, marital status.
前几天，我想弄清楚我的生命值多少钱，所以我去找了印第安纳州梅里尔维尔（Merrillville）的一位理算员乔治·卡拉斯（George Karas）。他打量了我一下，问了我的统计数据——年龄、职业、婚姻状况。
Right now, today, I'm willing to pay you $35,000.
现在，今天，我愿意赔你3.5万美元。
For my death?
为了我的死？
For your death. Total.
为了你的死。总共。
That's crazy.
这太疯狂了。
What do you think it's worth?
你觉得它值多少钱？
My life, worth less than half a second of one commercial on Seinfeld . George explains it this way-- I'm single, got no dependents. And as far as he's concerned, no one would be all that affected by my death. I argued with him, pointed out my parents need me. I make them laugh. I tease them in a way that nobody else can.
我的人生，价值还不到《宋飞传》（Seinfeld）里一个广告片半秒钟的价格。乔治是这样解释的——我是单身，没有受抚养人。据他所知，我的死亡不会对任何人产生太大影响。我和他争论，指出我的父母需要我。我让他们开怀大笑。我用别人无法做到的方式逗他们。
How often do they see you?
他们多久见你一次？
My mom sees me once a month, my dad every three months.
我妈一个月见我一次，我爸每三个月见一次。
Once a month and every three months. How close are you to them? Do you take them out for dinner? Do you always meet them on family holidays? Do you sit around the fireplace with them at night and roast marshmallows?
一个月一次和每三个月一次。你们有多亲近？你带他们出去吃晚餐吗？你们总是会在家庭聚会时见面吗？你们会在晚上围着壁炉烤棉花糖吗？
Those things are worth money?
那些事情值钱？
Absolutely. Loss of love and affection. In your case, there doesn't appear to be that strong emotional relationship.
绝对值钱。失去爱与情感。在你的案例中，似乎不存在那种牢固的情感关系。
Why, no, I'm very close to my parents.
为什么不，我和父母很亲近。
You see your dad once every three months. Does he send you a picture in between so you remember what he looks like?
你每三个月见一次父亲。在此期间他会寄照片给你，好让你记住他长什么样吗？
Girlfriends don't count.
女朋友不算。
They don't count?
她们不算？
Absolutely not.
绝对不算。
I see my girlfriend every day, and we're madly in love.
我每天都见我的女朋友，我们爱得如痴如醉。
If you love her that much, marry her. Show her the respect to quit shacking up and marry her. And then she'll count.
如果你那么爱她，娶她。尊重她，别再同居了，娶她。然后她就会算数了。
There's no government chart or general agreement on how much people are worth. If you die and it's someone else's fault, you could be worth as little as a few hundred bucks or as much as a quarter of a billion dollars to your survivors. To come up with a dollar amount for a person's life, insurance adjusters add fixed costs-- medical bills, funeral expenses-- to the more intangible costs, things like loss of comfort, love, affection, guidance.
没有政府图表或普遍协议规定人值多少钱。如果是因为别人的错而死，你的生命对幸存者来说可能只值几百美元，也可能值四分之一亿美元。为了给一个人的生命算出一个美元金额，保险理算员会将固定成本（医疗账单、丧葬费用）加上更无形的成本，比如失去安慰、爱、情感、指导。
Obviously figuring out the intangible values is more difficult, but there are basic principles that adjusters and the courts go by. The more people you have dependent on you and the more people you affect positively, the more you're worth. So if you want to increase your value, here's how. Join community groups, tutor some poor kids. Marrying your girlfriend or boyfriend adds a couple million dollars to your value. And while you're at it, have sex with them a lot. Losing the pleasure of sex with you can be worth hundreds of thousands of dollars. Remember, girlfriends don't count. Have a child. That will add another two million. A second or third or fourth child doesn't add anything.
显然，计算无形价值更困难，但理算员和法院遵循基本的原则。你有越多依赖你的人，你影响的人越多，你就越有价值。所以如果你想提升你的价值，这样做：参加社区团体，辅导穷孩子。娶你的女朋友或男朋友会给你的价值增加几百万美元。顺便说一句，多和他们发生性关系。失去与你的性快感价值数十万美元。记住，女朋友不算。生个孩子。那会再增加两百万。第二个、第三个或第四个孩子不会增加任何价值。
A college degree usually increases your value by millions, same for a high paying professional job. But if you really want to go for the hard cash, the thing to do is suffer. Nothing gets a jury going like misery. Another adjuster, Sarelle Povitsky, explained that to really increase your value after a tragic accident, don't die. Live, but be severely injured.
大学学位通常能增加数百万的价值，高薪专业工作也一样。但如果你真的想追求硬通货，该做的是受苦。没有什么比苦难更能触动陪审团了。另一位理算员，萨雷尔·波维茨基（Sarelle Povitsky）解释说，在悲剧事故后想要真正提升价值，不要死。活着，但受到重伤。
Yeah, right. Brain dead or paraplegic quads, those really demand a lot of money because there's so much future care involved in that. Yeah, the quad is worse because you are really struggling each and every single day.
是的，没错。脑死亡或四肢瘫痪，那些确实需要很多钱，因为涉及太多的未来护理。是的，四肢瘫痪更糟，因为你每天都在真正地挣扎。
To increase your value, I would probably say burn. That's the worst injury are burns.
为了提升你的价值，我可能会说烧伤。那是烧伤，最严重的伤害。
Why is that?
为什么这么说？
Because there's no relief from that pain. I mean, they put cream on them, but there's really no relief. There's nothing they can do for you. So I would say burns over most of your body would be--
因为那种痛苦无处可逃。我是说，他们会在上面涂药膏，但真的没有缓解。他们对你无计可施。所以我说全身大部分烧伤会是——
The best way to increase your value.
提升你价值的最好方法。
--the best way to increase your value. There's so much pain and suffering with that. And then the next thing would be to be brain dead.
——提升你价值的最好方法。那种痛苦和折磨太巨大了。其次就是脑死亡。
An insurance adjuster told me about a young guy driving a truck full of tires. He crashed. The car caught fire, and the tires pinned him inside. He slowly burned to death, begging for his life. He was a menial worker, single, no kids. Normally, the adjuster told me, he wouldn't be worth 30 grand. But his parents got a tremendous settlement because of his suffering. And it struck me, as I heard this, that in financial terms, the last 10 minutes of this man's life were worth more than the whole 25 years that came before.
一位保险理算员告诉我一个年轻人，开着一辆装满轮胎的卡车。他撞了车。车着火了，轮胎把他困在里面。他慢慢被烧死，乞求自己的生命。他是个卑微的工人，单身，没孩子。理算员告诉我，通常他只值3万。但因为他的痛苦，他的父母获得了巨大的赔偿。听到这个，我意识到，从经济角度看，这个男人生命最后十分钟的价值，比之前活过的25年总和还要多。
Anyone who looks at this stuff realizes pretty quickly that there's something irrational in all these schemes. For example, the single most important factor in determining your worth is not who you are, what you've done, who you love. It's the state or county where you die. In general, if you die in a big city, you'll be worth a lot more than if you die in a rural farming community. Juries in big cities are just more generous.
任何研究这些东西的人很快就会意识到，所有这些方案中都有某种非理性的东西。例如，决定你价值的最重要因素不是你是谁，你做了什么，你爱谁。而是你死亡所在的州或县。一般来说，如果你死在大城市，你的价值比在农村农业社区要高得多。大城市的陪审团更慷慨。
Adjusters say if you're going to die, die in Chicago or New York, preferably the Bronx, LA, Detroit. Florida is pretty good. Avoid New England, especially Maine. Stay away from the Rockies states. Don't die in Utah. You definitely don't want to die anywhere you can see the stars at night.
理算员说，如果你要死，就死在芝加哥或纽约，最好是布朗克斯、洛杉矶、底特律。佛罗里达也不错。避开新英格兰，特别是缅因州。远离落基山脉各州。别死在犹他州。你绝对不想死在任何能看到夜空星星的地方。
George Karas, the adjuster in rural Indiana, told me I would be lucky to get 50 grand for my life, but Sarelle, who works in Chicago's Cook County, knew her juries would be more sympathetic.
在农村印第安纳州的理算员乔治·卡拉斯告诉我，我能拿到5万就算幸运了，但萨雷尔在芝加哥库克县（Cook County）工作，她知道她的陪审团会更有同情心。
You have this future potential. God only knows where you could have gone with your degree and being a freelance person in communications. The whole world is open to you, and all of that is closed because you've died. So I would say that for sympathy factor, it's possible in Cook County to get a million dollar or better verdict.
你有这种未来的潜力。天知道凭你的学位和做自由传播职业的人，你能走多远。整个世界都向你敞开，但因为你死了，一切都终结了。所以我说，从同情因素来看，在库克县拿到一百万美元或以上的裁决是有可能的。
A million dollars, the price I dreamed of when I was seven. I asked Sarelle what I could do to increase my value even above that. And what she said kind of shocked and disappointed me. Essentially she told me I would have to reinvent myself. In particular, I would have to spend more time outside. It's a peculiar quirk of our legal system that people who enjoy outdoor activities are worth more than people who just stay inside and watch TV.
一百万美元，我七岁时梦想的价格。我问萨雷尔我还能做什么来提升我的价值超过那个数字。她所说的让我有些震惊和失望。本质上，她告诉我我必须重塑自己。特别是我必须花更多时间在户外。我们的法律体系有一个独特的怪癖，即享受户外活动的人比那些只待在室内看电视的人更有价值。
OK, here's what you should do to add value to your life, if you can. If you enjoy swimming or sunsets or gardening, or any of those things that create beauty in the world, try to do that, because that gives you added value.
好了，如果你能的话，你应该这样做来增加你人生的价值。如果你喜欢游泳、看日落或园艺，或者任何能在这个世界上创造美的事物，试着去做，因为那会给你带来附加价值。
Here's one thing I was thinking of. I like to read sort of obscure plays. I like to read sort of historical plays, which I'd imagine most people really could care less about. What about people who have-- let's say there's a guy, you could say he watches TV all the time, but what he's doing is he's watching videotapes of incredible foreign films. Is that going to--
有一件事我在想。我喜欢读一些生僻的剧本。我喜欢读一些历史剧，我想大多数人真的不太关心这些。那些——假设有一个人，你可以说他整天看电视，但他看的是精彩的外国电影录像带。那会——
Impact the verdict? No, I don't think so. See, the reason being-- so everybody watches TV and everybody reads. I don't know if it's necessarily the content that's important. The person that we're talking about who's involved in the community, who is very active in sports and loves sunsets, and all that kind of stuff, he gives more to the world than the person who maybe watches historical plays. You know what I mean? It's not content. It's the whole value of the person's life, what they've done with it, how involved they are. That gives you the greater value.
影响裁决吗？不，我不这么认为。因为——每个人都看电视，每个人都读书。我不确定内容是否必然重要。我们谈论的那个人，参与社区活动，非常热衷于体育运动，热爱日落，等等，他给世界带来的比看历史剧的人更多。你明白我的意思吗？不是内容问题。而是整个人生价值，他们用它做了什么，参与度有多高。那会给你更大的价值。
Right. Because the things that I feel add value to my life as I experience it, for me-- because I'm not much of an outdoors person-- what I feel adds the richness to my life personally really is reading. It's reading literature, reading nonfiction, and seeing wonderful films. I mean, that's something I really get a lot of deep pleasure.
对。因为作为体验，我个人觉得增加我生命价值的事情——因为我不怎么喜欢户外——真正给我生活带来丰富感的是阅读。是阅读文学、阅读非虚构类作品，看精彩的电影。我是说，那是我能获得很多深刻乐趣的事。
But I don't know that that adds value to your life, because we all do it. I love reading. I love going to movies. That's something you do personally. No one's dependent on you to do that. It's just something you yourself are being enriched from. And I don't know that that would have a great deal of value.
但我不知道那是否能增加你人生的价值，因为我们都这么做。我喜欢读书。我喜欢看电影。那是你个人做的事情。没人指望你去做那个。那只是你自己从中获得丰富的东西。我不知道那是否会有很大的价值。
So the jocks who I hated in high school and felt were worth less than I was, it turns out they're worth--
所以我在高中时讨厌的运动员，我觉得他们还不如我有价值，结果他们反而——
More. Yeah.
更有价值。是的。
We look to systems of rules, to how-to schemes, to create order out of situations that inherently defy rationality. And it always amazes me to think that when this particular system does its job, a check is cut, it has a dollar amount on it, and that's supposed to be the value of somebody's life.
我们寻找规则体系、操作指南方案，来从本质上违背理性的情况中创造秩序。每当我想起这个特定的体系发挥作用，开出一张支票，上面有一个美元金额，而那竟然是一个人的生命价值时，我就感到震惊。
I talked to one adjuster who said that when someone loses a loved one, they don't want money. They want to get rid of their pain. They want that person back. They're angry, and they want whoever caused the death to suffer. But the only thing we can give them is money. That's all we have. That's all we can do.
我和一位理算员谈过，他说当有人失去亲人时，他们不想要钱。他们想要摆脱痛苦。他们想要那个人回来。他们很愤怒，想要造成死亡的人受苦。但我们唯一能给他们的是钱。那是我们所拥有的全部。那是我们能做的全部。
Well this, of course, is the point in our program when we do the credits. And we thought, as part of that, we would have one last how-to. And to help with that how-to, I'd like to welcome to the program my dad, Barry Glass, now a certified public accountant in Baltimore, but in his younger days was a disc jockey in college radio and commercial radio.
好了，这当然是我们节目进行制作人员名单的时间。我们想，作为其中的一部分，我们要再加最后一个操作指南。为了帮助完成那个指南，我想欢迎我的父亲，巴里·格拉斯（Barry Glass）加入节目，他现在是巴尔的摩的一名注册会计师，但在他年轻时是大学广播和商业广播的电台DJ。
And, Dad?
爸爸？
Yes.
在。
Now, when you and I talked about the show, you've had a particular criticism of the way I do the show.
当我们谈论这个节目时，你对我做节目的方式有一个特别的批评。
Well, it was a constructive criticism. Let me put it that way. Let me start by being defensive.
好吧，那是建设性的批评。我就这么说吧。让我先开始辩护。
[LAUGHS] Well, it was a constructive criticism, which is why I invited you here today.
[笑声] 好吧，那是建设性的批评，这也是我今天邀请你来的原因。
And knowing from past experience, when I used to have to do things like closing credits, they get to be very mundane and things you do all the time. And sometimes you just roll right through them without a lot of emotion or maybe without sounding like a lot of caring. And that was my criticism to you.
根据过去的经验，当我以前必须做片尾字幕之类的事情时，它们变得非常世俗，是你一直在做的事情。有时你只是随口念出来，没有太多的情感，或者听起来不太有爱心。这就是我对你的批评。
Just so people at home can hear, let's just play some credits from a recent show so they can hear what you're talking about.
为了让家里的人听到，让我们播放一段最近节目里的片尾字幕，这样他们就能听到你在说什么。
Our program produced today by Julie Snyder and myself with Alix Spiegel and Nancy Updike. Senior editor Paul Tough. Contributing editors Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Rachel Day and [? Sohini ?] Davenport.
我们今天的节目由朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）和我自己制作，Alix Spiegel和Nancy Updike参与。高级编辑Paul Tough。特约编辑Jack Hitt、Margy Rochlin和顾问Sarah Vowell。制作帮助Rachel Day和[? Sohini ?] Davenport。
Now, Dad, explain to the nonprofessionals, what am I doing wrong there?
好了，爸爸，给非专业人士解释一下，我在那里做错了什么？
Well, you're just not giving it enough importance. You're anxious to beat the clock or something like that, or to get to a cup of coffee or I don't know what.
嗯，你只是没给它足够的重视。你急于赶时间之类的，或者急着去喝杯咖啡，我不知道。
Yeah. So give me some pointers. Give me some how-to.
是的。所以给我些提示。给我一些操作指南。
Well, I think you just ought to take your time and not rush through it so quickly, and try to give a feeling for the importance of the people who make the show go beside yourself.
嗯，我想你应该花点时间，别那么匆忙，尽量给那些制作节目的人——除了你自己以外的人——以应有的重视。
OK, well, why don't you and I split up the credits between us? You have a copy of the script there in front of you. You're speaking to me, I should say, by the way, from the studios of WJHU in Baltimore, the Public Radio affiliate there. And why don't you just start the credits?
好的，那我们为什么不分担一下字幕呢？你手里有剧本。顺便说一句，你应该是在巴尔的摩WJHU的工作室里跟我说话，那是那里的公共广播分支机构。你为什么不直接开始字幕？
Our program was produced today by Nancy Updike and Ira Glass with Alix Spiegel and Julie Snyder. Senior editor Paul Tough. Contributing editors Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and Sarah Vowell. Production help today from Rachel Day and [? Sohini ?] Davenport.
我们今天的节目由Nancy Updike和Ira Glass制作，Alix Spiegel和Julie Snyder参与。高级编辑Paul Tough。特约编辑Jack Hitt、Margy Rochlin和Sarah Vowell。今天的制作帮助来自Rachel Day和[? Sohini ?] Davenport。
To buy a cassette of this program, call us at WBEZ here in Chicago. The phone number, 312-832-3380.
要购买本节目的磁带，请在芝加哥拨打WBEZ电话。电话号码，312-832-3380。
See? I put in all those pauses. Was that good?
看？我停顿了所有那些地方。那样好吗？
Yeah. Wonderful.
是的。太棒了。
312-832-3380. Our email address, [? [email protected] . ?].
312-832-3380。我们的电子邮箱地址，[? [email protected] . ?]。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由公共广播国际分发。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who reminds you--
WBEZ管理监督Torey Malatia，他提醒你——
Don't die in Utah.
别死在犹他州。
Back next week with more stories of This American Life . I'm Ira Glass.
下周回来收听更多《美国生活》的故事。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
I'm Barry Glass.
我是巴里·格拉斯。
Don't drive like my father.
别像我父亲那样开车。
Please don't drive like my son.
请别像我儿子那样开车。
And don't drive like me.
也别像我这样开车。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。公共广播国际。